but let's go back to the first question
which is
where are you most likely to find a
virtuous man or woman
and i can hear curtis jarvin in my in my
ear telling me that we just need a
monarchy or a caesar of some monk temple
a monk temple a monastery
men above time this is a this is if you
want to google that go for it but men
above time are people that are separated
and distant from the current daily
goings-ons
and who can live a life of of of
contemplation and philosophy and
politics and you know there is some
there is some value to that and you know
when you're distracted with the
day-to-day material urges of the world
it's hard to be uh able to
philosophize in such a way that's best
for everyone without your own personal
stuff getting in the way honestly i
don't think any man can be virtuous by
nature i think we're all corrupt and and
prone to corruption we all need to eat
we all need to destroy life to consume
it to survive like that's nastily
corrupt from the beginning that's why
they say humans are dirty humans are
sinful by nature nature well it's it's
destructive it's it's it's vile it's
considered evil to the creature being
destroyed you know i suppose it's
terrifying to have to eviscerate an
animal and drink its blood to survive
but that's why you're not a predator if
you're not a predator it's not
terrifying it's a perfectly most natural
but we are predators
ian i think it's because
you've been insulated you live in a
bubble we all have i've been i've been
eating the flesh of the animals that i
never saw killed exactly exactly so
there's a lot of people who grow up in
the countryside who in their little kids
their dad hands them a gun and says you
know point it down keep your finger off
the trigger and we're gonna go hunt some
turkeys
and then they watch it happen by that's
by nature we're hunters killers you know
yes
i remember watching this old science
video where it was talking about
evolution and it was talking about like
plankton and plant cellular life and
then it was like and then one cell
attacked another and it absorbed it and
i was like and that was the beginning of
prediction and stuff like that and i'm
just like
yo i mean it's kind of crazy that there
are plants right chilling minding their
own business just doing their thing
they're like i'm gonna grow right here
because this is where i am and then they
grow and they're like i get my energy
from the from the carbon from the air
and the and the light from the sun and
i'm just minding my own business
building my own chemical structure and
then along comes some some chicken
and the chicken walks up and just goes
around rips it off
that that's so violent and that poor
innocent plant well yeah that's life
right are we gonna sit here and be like
animals should stop eating plants
because plants didn't do anything to
anybody or we're gonna be like we you
know we eat plants and we eat animals
right that is life so knowing that then
we have to decide who's going to be in
charge is it going to be a human because
they're vicious and they're hunters and
their killers and they need to survive
they need to kill to eat do you want
that person lording over you and your
family yes because they understand how i
survive thank you very much but they
don't even know who you are in this
country that's the problem this is the
problem it used to i think you know i
think it was you said the family is
communist right or you were quoting
somebody yeah i was quoting uh telev on
that right it's it's a really great idea
to say that at the smallest levels
leftism is perfect and then as you scale
up it just makes no sense as it gets
bigger and bigger it's idealistic it's
utopian and it'd be fantastic but once
you have different you know cities that
have different interests and different
needs there's going to be conflict
because people don't want to die so i'll
put it this way you hear these stories
about you know a shark attacking a
swimmer and they're usually like either
the shark was confused or desperate
there was a uh you know we had daniel
turner here and he was talking about how
the the foxes have been going after his
chickens and he was like normally they
won't do it now they are and i'm like
they're getting desperate the foxes
don't want to go near your house they're
scared of your house but when they have
nothing left to lose they have to make
they have to do something humans have
similar
situations where our country says we
have low food stores we have low energy
we have low of this material that we
need for our people we're getting
desperate what do we do and if they
can't get it from anybody else war
breaks out just like animals fighting
i i agree with that resource competition
has been a driver of conflict for a long
time but in the united states the the
conflict driver is our factions and our
different factions come from our
different faculties inside the united
states inside the united states yeah
so ideology is
i think for the most part unique to the
to to humans although we have seen
tribal warfare among uh some lower
primates
like you know apes yeah they fought each
other and now chimpanzees and that might
be a very very rudiment rudimentary
ideology but i don't think comes close
to what ideology actually is meant to
represent humans are literally going to
be standing there and someone's going to
be like
i think marx was right and then someone
else is going to be like you're nuts and
then he's going to pull out you know his
you know stone but even before we get to
competing ideologies within our own
ideological system there is inherent
competition based on the varying
faculties of men and by that i mean
each individual man has different
capabilities different interests
different uh ways that they can get
things accomplished in the world and so
therefore they're going to have rooted
interest in their faculties and because
we have different iqs and different
capabilities and people are taller and
shorter and stronger more inclined to
economics or real estate or agriculture
or whatever
as those people gain power then their
interests become factions and those
factions become competitive within the
united states and that's one of the
reasons why madison wanted us to have
such a wide-ranging expanse of a
republic so that there wouldn't be a
dominant faction within the united
states but then
woodrow wilson basically
legalized the faction of rockefeller and
jp morgan federal reserve military
industrial complex they built the school
system like that's basically a faction
don't say the school system again the
school system was founded at the time of
the founding for the purpose of creating
a patriotic fervor in the united states
you're saying the schools were created
to indoctrinate kids yes in american
love of america
but from what i've learned and i've
never gone through and that's not what
you you i i you i tell my friends so i
can say this but you say that's so
smugly to irritate me because you're
making a point it's sarcasm
it's sarcasm i'm trying to irritate you
i'm trying to you're trying to flip the
perspective on what it means right but
you're saying like oh it's to
indoctrinate kids into loving america i
know you're just making a point but like
yes that's exactly the point john and we
need that in 1903
rockefeller
the reason i bring this up is that
you know i've been mentioning a lot that
principle isn't necessarily the issue
it's it's it's often the subject or this
or the specific ideology and that's why
you might see a lot of people who are
immediately called hypocrites if you say
the indoctrination in schools is bad and
then you're like well the schools are
supposed to indoctrinate people but
towards what i want and then they say
well the school should indoctrinate
people towards what i want correct and
that's where the clash happens you're
both fighting over the ideology culture
crash in 1903 rockefeller founded the
general education board which provided
major funding for schools across the
country and so basically this his
faction
okay okay okay but that's 140 years
after or even more than that after the
establishment of public schools for the
purpose of creating patriotic citizens
yeah we're familiar with virtues and
republican government yeah well i guess
it's more about he amalgamated his no
he's still um he stole it his like get
ring when the bell rings you get up you
have to go to class or you'll be
penalized like show up sure take the
test
um
on top of the whole like moral thing
this is a good that's a good distinction
because i make this argument on twitter
often then people are like no i was
industrial people and they wanted to
train you to work in factories and
whatever whatever fine that may have
happened later but public schools are
designed to build patriots that function
well in our patriotic system
period
they wanted social cohesion yes when the
kids because this government needs i'm
sorry this kid this government needs a
particular kind of person well so this
is this is what happens when you have 13
colonies and they don't really agree
with each other a lot other than
independence and they need to stay
they're saying to themselves we need to
plant a tree whose shade we know we will
never sit beneath that is raise our
children to understand the values that
we have set forth and why it's a good
thing and everyone growing up should
understand what you know blood and
treasure was sacrificed for this
independence oh man you mentioned blood
and treasure
holy cow
if we
abraham lincoln said that if you violate
the law you disrespect the blood shed by
your forefathers i don't agree with that
not all laws are good law does not equal
the constitution let's say okay he
didn't say that though right he didn't
be violent
he he specifically was talking about
just law in general and love of country
he was a lawyer and he did have to do
that he had to become an autocrat to
keep the union keep the union yeah but
the point is is that
we here right now are having this
conversation because people that came
before us sacrifice their lives their
sons their treasure their wives their
family their homes all of it and to
disrespect the law that they created the
country that they created after that is
to disrespect them
and that is what his foundation of
political religion was which was the
idea that he had that he wanted to
animate the country with political
religion
a love of country a love of the
constitution a respect for the people
that died for it
because as time goes on you forget
he made address to this thing called the
lyceum
i want to say was around like 1830 or
1840
and at that time he identified the fact
that it had been sufficient enough time
that all of the the actual founding
fathers were dead and all the
revolutionaries were dead and all the
guys who lost sons and families and
fathers they were all dead so by 1840
1850 nobody remembered the fact that all
these people died for what we've got
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time